hello and welcome to the steep learning
tutorial part 2 this tutorial is about
object detection we will walk you
through tensorflow code using which we
will do object detection in images we
will tell you what are the libraries
that are required a little bit about the
cocoa dataset and then we will show you
the implementation code itself a demo of
the core alright so let's get started so
what is the tensor flow object detection
API it is an open source framework which
is actually provided by the tensorflow
team and there are trained models
available and the sample code is also
available which we can use in order to
easily detect objects in images and
videos this is pretty robust and can
detect objects fairly quickly and this
is very easy for people to use as well
people with very less or no knowledge of
machine learning or deep learning can
also but a little bit of Python
programming knowledge can actually use
this API this library to build object
detection applications this is a list of
libraries that are required and they
have been shown in the code as well the
exact purpose of each of this library
why it is required is out of the scope
of this tutorial but we will see in the
code as we walk through some of these
libraries how and why they are used the
cocoa dataset cocoa stands for common
objects in context so this dataset
consists of three hundred thousand
images of 90 most commonly found objects
like chairs and tables and so on and so
forth so this model has been trained or
in fact a set of models have been
trained on this data set and this is
pretty good to detect the most common
objects in the images and videos so with
that let's get into the chord all right
so the first part is to import all these
libraries and
thus we have shown you in the slides as
well again but part of this will be for
doing some helper functions and maybe
for visualizing the images and so on and
so forth so that's the reason they are
required as I said the exact details of
each and every library probably is out
of scope but these are needed so as the
first step maybe you just go ahead and
include these libraries and run the code
and maybe later point we can discuss
what each of these libraries does now
this will work with tensorflow version
higher than 1.4 so if you are having
test flow ocean below 1.4 you may have
to upgrade to a higher version so let me
go ahead and execute the cell and we
also need this line of code to make sure
that once we run this object detection
the labeled images are displayed within
this notebook and many of you by now
must be familiar with us and we will
import a few utility libraries and you
will see that we will be using some of
these for visualization purpose so once
the objects are detected we need to
display the information what that object
is and then what percentage of
confidence
the model has so all these details
that's the utility functions that start
here and then the next part is to
prepare the model as I mentioned we will
be using an existing trained model the
tensorflow team has actually provided
these models the one that we will be
using is SSD with the mobile net but you
can actually use any one of the ones
that are listed in this URL let me just
quickly take you through this URL these
are a bunch of models trained models
that are readily available for anybody
to use it is open source and let me
scroll down the only thing is that if
there are some of them with me the
accuracy is much higher but they take
longer and there are some where the
accuracy is not so high and they are
much faster so
they are faster but the accuracy may not
be that very high so you can play around
with some of these and we in this
particular exercise or in this
particular tutorial we are using this
SSD model which is SSD mobile net one so
that's the model that we'll be using
so in this cell we are primarily
creating a bunch of variables so that
the various for example the name of the
model the part and so on and so forth so
that we will be using these names in the
next step which is to download this
model and install it locally these are
also referred to as frozen model so once
they are trained and then you kind of
extract or you freeze the model so
that's the reason they're called frozen
model so that others can just use this
without any further training so this is
where we download and extract our model
locally so this will take a little while
let me see if I can wait or maybe pause
the video and come back once it is done
might take a little while let's see if
it completes I have a pretty high speed
network but even then it takes some time
so that's good but this part is over now
let us see this part yes both are done
so once that is done we need to load
some label mapping now basically what
this will do is your model as you may be
aware by now if you do some
classification the model will actually
not give any output text it will give
some numbers so if there are five
classes it will say okay this belongs to
model class one or two or three or five
and so on the numbers now each of these
will obviously the numbers will not make
any sense to the outside world so we
need to do some small mapping so in this
case let's say one may be a chair two
maybe a table three may be a balloon and
so on so that kind of number to text
mapping we need to do and that is what
is being done in this particular cell
and then we have a helper code which
will load the image and convert it into
an umpire array so that the number array
is what gets processed and used by
the model to do the detection part of it
so that is what this method is all about
so we will be that later on we will be
calling that function and next is
preparation for detection so here we are
basically telling where the images are
stored and how many images or what is
the naming convention or format of the
images now if you want you can modify
this code for example currently I have
test underscore images as my folder so
let me go and show this to you
so this is under my object detection
folder I have another subfolder where I
am storing my images which is text
underscore images now you can rename
this folder and give some other name and
then in your code you can probably give
that particular name for the support
similarly the format of these files
what is the name and format of this
files here it is in a very simple format
which is the names of the files are like
beach one Beach to Beach three and so on
so I have taken beach as the theme so I
have images which are related to beaches
so this is beach one beach two and then
each three are a few others but we will
use these three for our demo and so
that's what I'm saying here the name of
the images will be beach something dot
jpg which is jpg format and in this
curly braces basically we will will be
filled with either one two or three
based on in this particular for loop
okay so that is what this is doing
alright so the next step is to run
inference on these images in a loop and
what we are basically doing here is
getting these images one by one and then
running through the model to find out
what are the objects that can be
detected and then against each of the
object a box will be drawn and it will
be labeled with the name and the
percentage of accuracy or confidence
that the model detects these objects
okay so that is the function here and so
let me just run that piece of code and
here is basically where we are calling
this function so
loading those images and then we are
calling this function for each image and
then we are displaying this using the
matplotlib library so let's run this it
will take one image at a time and then
detect the images now the beauty is that
the same format of the code can be used
for doing object detection in a video so
we have another video for doing object
detection in a video so most of the code
out there will be reused from here and
only thing is that instead of reading
the images from the local storage we
read the frames from the video there is
a neat little video reader that is
available and it will be shown in the
other video and frame by frame we read
the video and then pass on to this
function and it will act as a feature of
these frames is an image and then it
will do the same object detection on the
entire video so that's in a separate
video just look out for that and
actually the information about that is
provided in the cards the eye symbol so
that's the the video object detection in
video that's the separate tutorials
alright so now that we have all the
pieces together this the last cell is
where the whole action takes place so
let's run this and see how it looks so
it will take probably a little while and
there are about three images let's see
what it detects there we go so good so
the first one it has detected a person
and that too with 97% accuracy which is
I think pretty good okay and then the
next image it detects umbrella and chair
there are few other options but it's not
able to detect that it has detected
umbrella with 63 percent accuracy or
confidence rather and the chair with 58
percent again not bad then let's see the
next image so here these are actually
balloons hot-air balloons but the model
thinks
it is a kite which is probably not that
bad
it sees there's something in the sky and
therefore probably it thinks it is a
kite and it detects that with 65 percent
confidence okay so that was pretty much
all I wanted to show you in this
particular tutorial about object
detection in images and that we come to
the end of this tutorial I hope you
liked it and if you have any questions
you have any comments please feel free
to write it below and don't forget to
watch the other tutorials does object
detection in the video all right thank
you very much once again and have a
great day hi there if you liked this
video subscribe to the simple learn
YouTube channel and click here to watch
similar videos to nerd up and get
certified click here